no Joey will turn to ashes in your mouth
and you will know the debt is paid you
owe a debt to the IRS I'm telling you if
you try and claim this red wedding as a
business expense it's gonna be a
bloodbath
Jamie Lannister you've been claiming
your sister's children as dependents
you'll have to pay fine oh so it's not
fraud after all that's good is that you
would have had to pay an arm and a leg a
hand
you want me to explain why you have to
pay taxes go ahead slowly you know pays
for roads drones that sort of thing
contraceptives not useful right now but
they might want them in the future
you're not fooling them they just paid
you they know what you are they know
it's all just an act you do realize that
the deadline is coming up right it's
it's in the middle of April you need to
ease into it do they know that the
Lannisters reported millions in gold
earnings last year but you only paid an
effective tax rate of fourteen point one
percent how blood spells curses
shape-shifting what do you think are you
suggesting that you can afford to pay
lawyers who will find loopholes for you
that give you a huge advantage over low
and middle income earners I'm entirely
sure you're entirely sure what I'm
suggesting yeah I understand how this
game is played we know about your secret
account in the Iron Islands
if you want justice you've come to the
wrong place
oh [ __ ] me